[تصفيق]
هو في 2009 بدات اسمع صلاح
جاهين كاي حد بيحب يسمع شعر او بيحب يقرا
عن الشعر عجبني الموضوع وكملت سمعت عن عبد
الرحمن الابنودي سمعت هشام الجخ سمعت
استاذ احمد فؤاد نجم سمعت الناس زي برضو
زي محمد ابراهيم ومصطفى ابراهيم ومحمد
السيد لو نسمع
عنهم
هنقول دلوقتي قصيده اسمها نهايه
الكون
اشياء في عالمنا
الغريب اذا رايتها فعلم ان هذه نهايه
الكون
اولها جسد
قويم اعلاه
التضاريس ويغطيه الفيزون
وشباب شباب بات طيله الليل يغذي
العيون ورجل في خلسه يدقق في
المضمون
وعجوز وعجوز حين لم يعجبه الوضع اتهم
بالجنون اذا رايت هذا فاعلم ان هذه نهايه
الكون
وشاب شاب يرتدي القميص
والبنطال وعلى وجهه البراءه وصلاح
الحال وحفظا للشهوات يبغي الزواج لعفه
ويرفض والعذر قله المال اليس هذا
بجنون اذا رايت هذا فاعلم ان هذه نهايه
الكون
واطفال
عرايا يبغون شربه
ماء اطفال عرايا يبغون شربه ماء واخريات
صبايا من الجوع يقضون الليل بكاء وذي
اللحا ذي اللحى يبغي حجب المواقع ويقول
ابتلاء فصدق من قال الدين للجهلاء كمدمن
الافيون واذا رايت هذا فاعلم ان هذه نهايه
الكون باسم
الدين باسم الدين تهتك
الاعراض فباسم الدين نعدم وباسم الدين
نقتل وباسم الدين نسح وباسم الدين تغرز في
قلب اخيك السكين
كل هذا باسم الدين فمن ذا الذي عينك الها
واليك
الساجدين منذ
متى منذ متى يا اشد الصامتين عند نصره
المظلوم قلت حرام منذ متى يا من لا تفقهون
الا الكلام منذ متى يا علماء
السلطان ايا من يكون وان
عارضنا فنحن قوم
كافرون اذا رايت هذا فاعلم ان هذه نهايه
الكون يسرق
المعدوم يسرق المعدوم فبلا نقاش تقطع اليد
بلا نقاش تقطع اليد حين يسرق المعدوم بلا
نقاش تقطع
اليد ويرش المسؤول ف الصبر الصبر ويسمع
منه الرد وصاحب الجاه حين نفس الفعله يكاف
ثم يقال تطبيق الحد فكل هذا من سنه الرسول
مسنون اذا رايت هذا فاعلم ان هذه نهايه
الكون ومسجد في
الفجر مسجد في الفجر لا يجد من يم
الصلاه مسجد في الفجر لا يجد من يم
الصلاه وقلوب حتى الصباح تترنح على انغام
العندليب وسواه ف والملهى الليلي يتارجح
من دب الاقدام اعلاه فاللي خمر ونساء وغدا
جمعه نام الصلاه وعند النصح يقال
جنون اذا رايت
هذا فاعلم ان هذه نهايه
الكون والام
تبكي الام تبكي ليل
نهار الام
تبكي ليل نهار على ولد ان مات الانف في
النار الام تبكي ليل نهار على ولد ان مات
الان ففي
النار والاب يكدح في العمل ويلعق الجمر
حتى يريح الابن طيله
العمر فلا تبكي يا امي ولا تجدح يا ابي
فالابن غارق يشرب
الخمر
والبنت البنت ملفوفه في العباءه
لف وما تحت العباءه ما وصف
وشف وعند
النزول عند النزول تسدل العباءه والمنظر
اشبه بشريط سف وعند النصح يقال شباب
مفتون الام تبكي ليل نهار على ولد ان مات
الان ففي النار والاب يكدح في العمل ويلعق
الجمر حتى يريح الابن طيله العمر
فلا تبكي يا امي ولا تجدح يا ابي فالابن
غارق يشرب الخمر والبنت ملفوفه في العباءه
لف وما تحت العباءه ما وصف وشف وعند
النزول تسدل العباءه والمنظر اشبه بشريط
سف وعند النصح يقال شباب
مفتون اذا رايت هذا فاعلم ان هذه
نهايه
الكون ثم
ننام ثم ننام كل
ليله ثم ننام كل ليله والنوم يملاه
الشخير ومع كل
نومه تغتصب
الاراضي والبغاء على السرير وعلى الفراش
اثار الجماع ومن البرد نلتف بالفراش كبرد
الحمير ثم نرتمي في احضانهم ونرجو ما كان
الا
يصير ثم نرتمي في احضانهم ونرجو ما كان
الا يصير فعذرا يا بلادي ولك الله يا ارض
واطفال الحجاره كفيلون باقص الاسير
فحكاه
غافلون
وشعوبنا
نائمون والشعر باطل
والقائل سيفه لم يعد
مسنون اذا رايت هذا فاعلم ان هذه نهايه
الكون الفصل
الاخير
ساداتنا
يقال ان
ساداتنا تاكدنا ان
ساداتنا
كاذبون واولياؤها
مترفون
واباؤنا هم من يذكرون
وابناؤنا في كل ليله للخمر
يشربون والصالحون منا في كل واد يحاربون
والشاعر منا في كل واد يهيمون فالشعر
فالشعر باطل ان لم يحرك ساكنا
وقائله كتاجر
للافيو ثم نبيع
الدنيا ثم نلوم
الدنيا ثم نعيب الدنيا ونحن اكبر عيوبها
ان كانت مليئه بالشر فمنا وان كانت تحوي
الخي فقد اثقب
جيوبها حتى فاض الكيل بها فطاح بنا يمينا
ويسارا حتى وصفت بالجنون واذا رايت كل هذا
فتاكد
وثق ان هذه نهايه الكون
وشكرا
نكمل
شعر طبعا انا قلت ان انا كنت بدايه الحوار
مع استاذ صلاح جاهين
رباعيات للي ما يعرفش الرباعيه الرباعيه
دي عباره عن اربع ابيات بتوصل مضمون صغير
يعني
ف هقول اول
رباعيه دمع
عينيها دمعت عينيها من كتر
الفرحه والدبله في
ايديها وعلى راسها
الطرحه غمضت عيني سرحت لقيتها ل فتحت
لقيتها هي كمان
سارحه خلصت
[تصفيق]
الربع كمان واحده
عصفور
الصباح عصفور الصباح يا واقف فوق
الشجر نسيم المحبه يا فاح من بين ضلوعك
انهمر يا ترى بحلم يا ناس ولا العصفور هو
اللي
فجر
بس هما اربع ابيات بالظبط ف ما بنطول ش عن
كده
يعني نختم
بواحده مغرور اللي شاف الدنيا
عروسه وهو
عريس
مغرور اللي فاكر الدنيا عروسه وهو
عريس مجنون اللي شايف نفسه حاوي وحاوي
الدنيا في كيس بكره كله يبان ويطلع الحاوي
غلبان ومبان في ن واعظ مش بعيد يطلع
[تصفيق]
ابليس